[Music]
it's easy to see why people might wish
to prolong their own lives it's a rather
selfish pursuit unless you recognize and
do something about the fact that birth
rates are not declining and in the world
as a whole and the population is rising
rapidly there may be more people alive
today than they have that then there are
dead people so to speak I mean it may be
to add up the total number of people
alive and then say how far back would
you have to go in time if you integrate
it all peep all dead people backwards
until you reach the same number as are
now alive it will be an astonishingly
long time ago
so to prolong human life in an
irresponsible profligate way would be
indeed irresponsible unless you at the
same time reduced birth rates if
everybody lived forever then we better
stop anymore any new people being born
otherwise we're going to be hideously
overcrowded and it's a rather
presumptuous arrogant thing to do some
might say to say right well the present
generation are the last ones to
reproduce we better all just just sit
here and enjoy our lives well for
thousands of years well obviously a long
way away from that now but I know there
are some people who who see that as a
kind of ideal and they certainly need to
think seriously about what to do about
population size
[Music]
you